[Music]
just a little throwback I'm glad we
didn't to bring that back every now and
then all right every now shut out to
Ellis yes Williams voice that former
employee disrespect to Rod sim but no
disrespect sir I had no idea that was
going on when that showed me is how much
of a control freak I am I like how to
twinge on the back what is this well I
thought it was like they hit the wrong
file but that was you yeah T weird not
only are gonna have Fenric here for the
whole time potentially no guarantees but
we're gonna get a lot of time on radio
5:30 so I'm out of here
okay that's three so I'm the only one
that went to three our podcast yes all
the time and the YouTube commenters
people on YouTube right back I'm amazed
how can you people that listen to us
like us that much what is wrong with you
people from liking us and listening to
us that long we have a lot to get to we
are going to get to the Patriots cook
trade in our own way we are bringing
back the out of left go field hat so we
can have random questions throughout the
time we're also gonna have a few other
segments including favorite quotes of
the last two days we are going to do a
new segment called Adam left go steals
his neighbors newspaper and brings
certain topics to Simms cuz he thinks
there's funny so I steal one newspaper a
week from my neighbor wow that's that's
against the law that's stealing mail
that's a federal you don't think up your
newspaper by noon it's my newspaper and
filling time with Phil Simms Phil we'll
be back and of course we're gonna get to
your corner back breakdowns we have a
lot of fans that have submitted
cornerback plates it's a great it's
another great discussion of positions
they're really
feeling that you're again shocked at how
some people are deemed to be really good
I I am always at this position and
there's some other guys too that I will
get into it I don't even know how I have
them ranked yet I'm gonna talk it out
and rank it with people I'm gonna call
our scouting segments are you even
watching because what happens is Sims
watches three games of each then goes
are you even watching how did we get
here with Sam done right like I mean are
you even watching conversation for me
right now would start with DJ charkh at
LSU I don't work that's why I receive
her yeah I just want to say that like
that to me like okay six three two
hundred pounds fastest guy in the draft
great route runner running by everybody
in the SEC grated adjusting the ball
down the field but not talked about in
the first round that just it balls my
mind but yet like guys like Kelvin
Benjamin and Josh Dotson and brashaad
Perryman are like that that's where I go
Rashad Perryman had what I like to call
the old pro the old pro day bump right
when you run in a pro day and then
everyone's like it's the last thing they
saw they ride like a 4-0 but this guy
runs for two on the field he's one of
the best punt returners in the draft
minutes
anyone tell us you anybody else you
sounds like some freaky athletes from
that school I don't know 60s 60s whoa
Chucky be go Chucky Ben Eric Chuck
Bednarik vendrick pop quiz what was
Chuck Bednarik s-- nickname no idea
concrete Charlie I wouldn't care to know
that either no I knew it but I wouldn't
have came a home game Hall of Fame
Center linebacker five-time AP all-pro
two-time Super Bowl champ or excuse me
NFL chambray with the Philadelphia
Eagles knocked Frank Gifford out of
football for like a year and a half yeah
awesome
Chucky B Tommy nobis did you put Tommy
nobis in the great Texas line back at
the war number 60 no nope how about Brad
Benson the left tackle for the 1986
Super Bowl champion New York Giants how
about that you didn't put that in though
how dare you damn I have some 60s I
played with and I can't think of their
names right now I'll fill the time with
my boy all legs and a steam for the
University for Rutgers University Rimmel
Meekins take a look at his ass sack and
Brian Brown there in 2006
I mean I mean it's Rutgers Rutgers he's
in a position to wear your legs and ass
would look I mean you might look like
you have legs and ass in that position
look at his eyes but you're right I'm
seeing other pictures to support it
they're pretty good anyway Ramel Meekins
did tackle for Rutgers
it's about all my sixties I got I her
sixties what do you guess I almost had
University of Records I heard back a
little rusty no but and Rick's excited
about it style of the mic today re Quan
Joe of the Washington Redskins TJ these
are the centers TJ Johnston the bengals
graham glasgow of the Lions david
andrews of the patriots max Unger of the
Saints Ben Jones of the Titans who's the
best of that bunch Unger alright Sam
Johnson great Glasgow Andrews Unger
Jones oof that's a pretty good group
right there actually I thought so too
yeah I would probably go with own gurkha
but Jones and and and even the kid up in
Detroit Glasgow Alaska there Detroit is
gonna have a sneaky good ol line now
that they don't have Decker out for the
first eight games like last year right -
right guards currently AJ can of the
Jaguars Connor McGovern of the Broncos
and right tackle Darryl Williams of the
Panthers some throwbacks from the 60s
the Titans Jets Larry Grantham was a
linebacker back in the 70s and 80s for
the Rams right guard Dennis Hara and
then a defensive end in the inn that
went from 78 to 90 al Bubba Baker was a
P Defensive Rookie of the Year
three-time Pro Bowler Shawn O'Hara oh
damn
rusty for the Giants and then which one
of these guys was better right
D'Brickashaw Ferguson were 60 or Chris
Samuels from the Washington Redskins was
their left tackle yeah I always knew he
was great because when I played Madden
in that era he was always like 97 98
good yeah Samuels or D'Brickashaw
Ferguson I think it's a total career I'd
go Samuels I think that you know Moore's
Pro Bowlers yeah more size and strength
and vertebra cushaw debris Shaw was
really good I mean he was a franchise
left tackle but it was all athleticism
and he had a good anchor but he wasn't
quite the powerful man Samuel was what
is amendment number two Sims Kyle
Shanahan's
coach in the NFL first question only
question only question what do you think
Kyle is thinking about with all these
Rams moves right now so the Rams have in
da mic and Su Marcus Peters Aqib Talib
now they trade and get Brandon cooks
right in addition to all the great guys
they already had Aaron Donald is
practicing against knives practicing
against knives what do you think Kyle
Shanahan's thinking about all this Josh
how would you feel if like your good
friend was the head coach of like your
arch nemesis and I'd be [ __ ] pissed
right and he has a good team and dare
you speak Abby's not sleeping well they
staying late at the office right I mean
again hey we've talked about this before
this is more you guessing this is just
me knowing both of them there's a
competitiveness year that I am so
excited to see going forward I mean this
this has the potential for me to be the
greatest rivalry in the NFL here
sometime in the next not only because
they're talented they have money they
got players coming San Francisco's a
year to find young quarterbacks right so
there's some and then oh we play each
other twice a year and they live in the
same state and you know one guy coached
under the other guy for a number what
kind of competitive are we talking like
Harbaugh Schwartz like running up to
each other knowing like a healthy
respect of like I think both guys really
like each other they like the person
they'd love to hang out and have beers
together but they want to make sure
they're the first one to win a playoff
game or win a Super Bowl or my question
is if you went out to dinner with
McVeigh and Kyle Ryan let's say it was
pretty like cool yeah do you think when
you left both of them might text you and
be like how about that [ __ ] no no
neither way no I think they truly like
each other yeah yeah it's not none of
that yeah I mean McVeigh's more likely
to text you would go hey that was a nice
dinner good to see you see you soon man
yeah Kyle is not gonna send you anything
he says they gotta talk to you later bro
so yeah Kyle's be like just check up the
check see you later bro picking up the
check if I'm at the dinner them too what
cash I mean let's get to the trade ok
treats ramse
i have cooked up some questions for the
Patriots Rams
just hear the details Patriots get the
23rd pick Rams of course get Brandon
cooks the Patriots now have the 23rd
pick the 31st pick the 43rd and the 63rd
but really three in the top 43 is pretty
amazing right this is the Rams offense
Goff Gurley Brandon cooks Robert woods
Cooper Cup Everett and Higby those are
all of the weapons that they have and
that's not even including Tavon Austin
yeah putting on their roster right now
right and then you have some backup
running backs that have talent as well
they're pretty awesome gone for it I
mean is it going for it it made me
though think of a story when I first
moved to Kentucky I bought a dresser and
I bought it for like $100 off of a
friend and I lived there for like three
and a half years and as I was moving out
I put my dresser on Craigslist and I
sold it for $100 and I was like this is
genius
like in essence I paid nothing but I got
a dresser for three years
last year the Patriots traded a 30
second pick for Brandon cooks paid him
1.5 million dollars for a season right
and then traded him for the 23rd pick in
the first round yeah I was excited for
getting a dresser for free
they got Brandon cooks and then moved up
eight spots in the draft that's pretty
amazing
I mean Belichick just rented a receiver
and then got eight picks for it well I
mean again everything you read it's
insane it's why he's the master of the
universe or the evil dark haired
soulless wandering eye the soulless
wonder right whatever it is but you know
he just is such a unbelievable thinker
and because of that he can see the
future a little bit too and I think if
we went back in time and thought like
put tried to put yourself in bills shoes
now he goes oh okay I'll trade him he's
an integral part of our offense we
really need him to be successful we have
no Julian Edelman all of those things
are going to play so he's going I need
to win right now and he's gonna go you
know what and and in our offense I'm
gonna make him look probably better than
he was in New Orleans so his rise will
go up so maybe I can pressure in them
they're taking a long-term deal for
lesser than what he's worth which is
what it sounds like they tried during
the season or right I'm not gonna just
let them walk out of here for free
I'll make them look good enough to wear
and you think we maybe get something a
little bit better than what I gave for
them right all right so I have come up
with a number of questions like how are
they gonna do I'm gonna put it in the
Hat and pendrick is gonna pick it out
pendrick I don't get it drum roll yeah I
know I'm just saying we're picking it
out of the Hat simms pendrick Lefko and
the first pick Patrick what is the first
question are the Rams better with cooks
instead of Watkins Sims I'll let you
have the floor on this one Wow
that's a good question good question
laughs cow thanks I do think there
overall better than yes
really I do yeah I I mean Brandon cooks
he is not as fast as Sammy Watkins but I
think as an overall all-around football
player he's got a little more
versatility he's a better route runner
and I would think that he would get some
type of long-term contract that's gonna
be in that type of range of 15 million
dollars a year I mean I think that's
what he's gonna ask for right he's gonna
say I've had three out of three out of
four years of my career Ben thousand
yard seasons right I mean I've had a
better career than Sammy Watkins at this
point he's gonna be able to say that but
you think the flow of that offense like
he can still be the deep threat that
Watkins was 3-8 underneath the cup and
Robert woods and all that didn't
definitely do that but I think the thing
I like about it too is like woods can do
a little bit of both and so can cooks
and that's what I liked so yeah you
don't know Oh which guy is gonna be
underneath those guys going D go back
welcome Texans game for the Patriots
last year we kind of took over at the
end sure his ability on the sidelines
and I think there's a lot better than
walking yeah you're right Watkins is is
more OneNote right it's either screen
and go right or going guy
whereas cooks can play underneath this
as long as Malcolm Jenkins isn't there
but but you're right about that I mean
and and and Watkins clearly could have a
better year - because Watkins has a
special skill set that's gonna fit that
office there - so
bombs away with mahomes right yeah you
might see Watkins with a better year ago
that's not even close or whatever okay
well in the Ram system I don't know if
he'll be
as good as Brandon cooks will be alright
vendrick the second question after the
Patriots Rams trade is is Bill Belichick
sabotaging the Patriots on his way out
the door I mean there's part of me that
like Malcolm Butler in the Super Bowl
yeah there's part of me that hopes that
Bella check is like secretly like
building like this one trapdoor that
when he's done he just goes and it all
falls apart
I mean there's that it's it's nothing
that people talk about around the NFL I
mean I don't I mean yeah there's there's
definitely talk that people think
Belichick is you know so crazy and so
wants it done his way that his he's
stuck to the Patriots by not playing
Malcolm Butler I mean he obviously
thought he could win in the Super Bowl
but it was sticking it to Malcolm Butler
for not taking the deal he offered you
know sticking to Robert Kraft for not
for sticking his nose into too many
football situations I mean that's the
way he is to a degree and you're telling
us this is a real thing that's discussed
at the NFL this is like conversations
were like literally I've had coaches or
front office people like I mean like do
you think you wanna prove a point the
Super Bowl like what is he doing I and
it's like legitimately being talked
about yeah he's that stubborn now he
also is like either Kista cool enough to
go well I'm good enough coach we'll
figure it out without Malcolm Butler
anyways and we'll make it work but I
don't know what the hell they're doing
up there right now I'm really interested
to see what they're doing what their
plan of attack is can you really say
they're gonna parlay these picks into a
quarterback I mean it's find out it
might be one of the questions coming up
in the Hat Oh questions has any wide
receiver had a better OC career than
Brandon cooks Sean Payton Josh McDaniels
and Sean McNabb no I was thinking about
that last night here we are going Oh
Brandon cooks had a better career than
Sammy Watkins and I'm going yet because
he's played for maybe the three best
offensive coordinators in the NFL shop
Peyton McDaniels and Sean McVeigh he if
he goes to another team also I don't
think anyone's been traded as much as
Brandon cooks in their career right this
is unbelievable but if he goes somewhere
else he'll be shell-shocked if it's not
a good OC
he won't even know what to do send him
up to Green Bay next that's what I'm
saying I mean he's played for three guys
who else is good a Matt like I know
matters at some point he's the luckiest
mf'er we've ever seen well that's what's
annoying is I remember when I tried to
interview Brandon cooks and I emphasized
try because Brandon's not a guy that's
gonna give you anything he's gonna give
all praise to God and not tell you
anything which whatever it's just not
good for an interview he I was like you
know compare of Sean Boehner Josh we
know he's the other both good and I'm
like man if if we got like a Martellus
Bennett that worked with all three guys
we could really learn a lot about what
it's like to be with them bran is just
not gonna give you that no but what a
great career for him man great career
it's like I was just trying to think of
like things like similar like Wes Welker
getting to play with Brady and then
Manning right being in that offense and
then I think of the other guys I'd like
to find guys that played for like the
worst offensive coordinators and who
their careers will never be as good as
Brandon cooks and I simply because of
the circumstance of the teams they went
that's what's amazing about Beckham jr.
cuz he's doing that and we're still
going he's the best in football same
draft same draft same mean he's
hands-down been the shittiest offensive
it's really interesting is out draft in
itself in 2014 Brandon cooks plays for
these offensive coordinators Odell plays
for them Mike Evans has played for Dirk
cutter and he still put up number up
Allen Robinson had a mix of like
Nathaniel Hackett and Greg Olson
regulation but no I would say that
Brandon cooks has had the best yeah yeah
it's like the other thing that came to
my mind was just like just play
quarterback Kurt Warner right like Kurt
Warner he got to play with all that
talent on the Rams and then he got to go
to Arizona and it was Larry Fitzgerald
Anquan Boldin and he Breaston and
Whisenhunt was kind of new as OC in the
NFL is your career is your life -
because you're a Super Bowl winner that
totally changes what you can do after
football everything I mean it's a life
changer no doubt yes and then just go
work for the NFL Network and they're
gonna be the ones that get you into the
home a Hall of Famer right next question
should the Patriots trade both
first-round picks for Odell Beckham jr.
oh gosh that's the second thought that
went through my head I mean the first
thought that went through my head is ooh
are they gonna make a move for a
quarterback right ii thought that went
through my head is alright
enough to go after Odell Beckham jr.
about 2007 Patriots I'm an AK bring back
the Randy Moss with Tom Brady now that
he can like throw it deep again with
Gronk and and Rex Burkhead and Chris
Hogan and Malcolm Mitchell's coming back
it'd be amazing but I'd have a hard time
thinking that they would value that
position quite like that at this point
do you think I melonchek likes Odell
Beckham jr. do you think he looks at him
the way he looks at an e diri yes I do
respect I do you think that if if Odell
he would be like this talent we could do
incredible things with I do I think he
could go there and be incredible he
could also be smushed personality-wise
and I won't tell about what it was like
when you saw Oh Joe cinco in doing yeah
oh just think it was so out of place in
New England and I could tell every day
like he just didn't he wasn't
comfortable in his own skin cuz he
couldn't be Oh de Ojo cinco he even told
me that you thought that he was gonna he
thought that he was gonna come in there
and be like I'm gonna loosen up the pack
yes no and that doesn't it doesn't
happen especially when like guys like
Vince Wilfork and Brady are in there and
go no this is the way we are in this
locker room we're not
this isn't Cincinnati or how did Otis
group how did he react to all that could
you see it like well I saw it when I
feel like he totally lost personality I
feel like even before practice he was
stressed out and I want to be like damn
it's May 7th dude like relax at the same
time but we're showing Co was at his
career that's not compare compared to
her Odell is right not comparable not
comparable and the only reason it works
for Gronk is because he's the best in
history yeah and and also what happened
to Ocho Cinco is he was in Cincinnati
and a West Coast type of offense he was
in a once this scheme with a totally
different language and it was kind of
simple and he got to New England and it
was like no detail do your job every day
it's a really complicated offense and
holy crap I'm thinking about a lot and I
can't figure it all out and I think it
just wore on him not physically and
mentally so ok but but to where he just
couldn't let his physical ability show
out and I don't think he was as good as
bill thought he was at that point of his
career so what percentage are we putting
at the Patriots trade in these guys I
mean I so I did it like we talked about
this conversation on Pro Football Talk
the other day and we asked we were one
of the things we said is where would you
like to see him go and I said the
Patriots would be my number one place
I'd like to see him go
because again they would be able to use
him better than anybody other than maybe
the McVeigh's of the Shanahan's or Sean
Payton yes but they're gonna be he's
gonna be all over the field then you're
gonna look at the end of year ago well
he's leading the NFL and all prophecy
would be fulfilled if Brady wins his
last Super Bowl with Odell Beckham oh my
gosh that would be amazing but I you
know you one thing you hear a lot from
New England people and even people like
Bill just wants to coach people he likes
and wants to coach at this point in his
career so yeah does he like an Odell
Beckham jr. and were a little too much
personality for Bill you know he's not
good for choir boys like you said I you
talked to her earlier like Randy Moss
was on his radar
but Randy is not like quite the
personality that are no doubt Beckham
jr. yeah and Odell has less
off-the-field issue he does you're
exactly that's a great point you made
Ryan Randy ran over a traffic wrap right
Odell's danced and faked peed and
proposed to Odette yeah I know get off
his back I know let's go to another
question
oh it's a long one left go to follow
okay here we go
so don't read both will this trade lead
to Sims obtaining true articles Oracle
status from his November predictions
yeah so I went and found that clip
November 1st 2017 you said I just got
this weird feeling that I'm looking
around and I think the Patriots soon
could trade up and and go and get the
quarterback of the future did it make
you like are you feeling super confident
about that right now because you even
said Josh Allen back in November go
ahead and watch Teddy yeah all right so
two things anything the first thing I
would think is there's only two
quarterbacks I think in this draft that
they would be interested in the first
round and that's only Josh Allen and
Rosen the other three don't fit what
their oldest were four quarterbacks in
the NFL so I would have a hard time
thinking that Lamar you know doc darn
'old or Baker Mayfield or they're kind
of guys because they don't even fit like
the criteria the baseline criteria as
far as what they want at the quarterback
position so I do think that strongly I
think I think what's I think a three
that's problem it's the end of the first
round yeah but they also have that Earl
they have two early second rounders in
31 and 43 43
the other second ones of the end of the
session Oh 23 31 43 is that enough to
move up I know is that going to move you
up into the top five from all the way
they're in a drought that doesn't have
necessarily amazing elite talent so
that's my other question which team
would actually trade with them right
who's good like do you think teams would
want to trade with Belichick no
everybody's scared to trade for belt
would Belichick but I do think there's
teams out there that'll be interested in
it because I think they're all gonna
know at that point to like okay he's
coming up to get a quarterback I mean
right he's not coming up here to gets a
qualm barkley like out of the position
he's never valued ever and also it's
gonna value it right so I did think of
all those the thing that you know with
the quarterback situation too I don't
know if there's a guy worth at pick 43
in the quarterback situation right so
they're in a very weird spot and you're
right they might have to give up another
first rounder somewhere along the line
it's to get all the way up because teams
are gonna look at them ago first-round
picks from New England or the end of the
first round early second that's
basically what it is you know so you're
not feeling confident I mean I just feel
like it's gonna take a lot and I have a
hard time thinking Bill's gonna go like
here's three first rounder for Josh
Allen but if it does Oh awesome he'd be
the cold Yahoo yeah follow up question
from left go if the Patriots move up to
select Lamar Jackson will the world
explode trade up to like 15 and snag
Lamar Jackson move them to receiver no
no if they go there and they go our
quarterback of the future we are going
to build an entire offense we see that
the RPO is taking over we just got
destroyed by it Super Bowl right and we
want the perfect RPO guy to sit behind
Tom Brady for a year or two and then
everyone in the NFL just goes holy crap
why were we afraid to do this yeah I am
well that's what's gonna happen with
Lamar Jackson that's really that's what
I have vision it's like three years from
now everybody every fan from those teams
that missed up an eyebrow how do we put
him up I mean that's what I really do
envision happening and I think the tide
has changed already on Lamar Jackson as
much as the off the field has been a
disaster I mean every day you wake up
and there's more first-round chatter for
this wide receiver at quarterback I
heard your teammate Booker McFarland
though talk on TV today and said he
should switch to Y versa that's just
insane I was like booger can I don't
want to talk Shea talks about don't
touch it's alright but yeah bigger than
me works in New York that's your right I
don't want to get in trouble yeah no I
don't I don't see that sorry my response
to that would be like are you even
watching all right another one will obj
still get traded
now that the rams are out of the running
I do think that is certainly a still big
possibility he's gonna get what they
want it's the Giants yes i do i do i do
i just it's gonna be rich to get it
whatever it is
who do you think are the leaders in the
clubhouse to get Odell right I mean
obviously the Niners the Niners are the
like the number one team and again this
is a type of conversation where I know
Kyle thinks Odell Beckham jr. is awesome
but I don't even get into these
conversations with Kyle because I don't
want to know his answer because then I
won't be able to talk about it we talked
earlier about a rivalry right is there
any chance that that plays trading for
Brandon cooks will even further motivate
the Niners to trade for Odell Beckham I
think all of it has to I mean Marcus
Peters a key to leave and Domenic ensue
they're just looking at going damn
they're getting more talented and we
haven't really found the right guys and
it hasn't been the right year for free
agency for them for some of their team
needs to so that they were smart in the
fact that they didn't just panic and pay
players just to go oh when we need a guy
here so that I like but yeah the 49ers
are certainly would be in that
conversation isn't that short to
prioritize Odell just because of what
one of your divisional rivals is doing
yep well you feel like you do get
competitive and feel like listen we may
get a lot of difference makers and I get
that but yes I think it would have to be
one of those things where yet they want
to make that happen now you go study
Odell and you go wait is my reaction
worth this player and then they're gonna
watch the film ago holy [ __ ] he's
[ __ ] amazing let's give up our next
seven first-round picks for him all
right so I'm a the Niners I would think
like a team like the New York Jets
wouldn't even think about it why
wouldn't the Houston Texans think about
it they got money in deshaun Watson and
Billy O'Brien
and will fuller in DeAndre Hopkins in a
while and Frank Reich want to get Odell
Beckham jr. in there with Andrew Luck
hmm and Chris Ballard and look why I
mean so again I don't have any knowledge
of this thing right I know that
everybody's interested just because of
the way I told you at the the owners
meeting how many people came up to me
and just asked me hey what do you know
about Odom do you know he plays for the
Giants you don't need the guys on the
judge so even though the Rams were
easily the number one contender for him
you think that the odds they're 50/50 I
would say they're right doc oh yeah yeah
I mean the fact that shefter is still
coming out every day and going it's
still gonna happen it's still gonna
happen exactly guys that is a that is a
reporter afraid of getting scooped
because he knows that there's that much
it's happening yeah there's too many
teams I think they're laying in the
weeds doing their home but what the
thing that's going on with Odell right
now everybody's checking is off the
field stuff that's what everybody's
doing
how followed by a private investigator
how often does that stuff happen a lot
and I know we're we gonna we're gonna
talk about this a little bit like I mean
we'll hear about Odell's yeah yeah I
would think that of a team is going to
trade for Odell Beckham jr. that yes a
team before they do that is gonna have a
private investigator follow him for two
or three weeks these people are hired by
the teams individually not because a lot
of the teams have high security guys
that were either X FBI guys F Nate X
navies whatever it may be there in the
security business and then they know
other security people John Lynch is
sitting in his office ago Barry hi
O'Dell follow him for a few weeks let me
know what he's doing let me know where
he's eat let me know if he's going out
at night I mean again I don't know that
John Lynch is doing that but I'm just
saying you think GM's and stuff but all
the top so if the top five quarterbacks
in the draft are all being followed by
private investigators every single one
of them hands down without a doubt
no no doubt we're talking about
right-wing conservative NFL they're
gonna be oh I don't know if I can draft
them if he eats pizza on Wednesday night
lets in follow investigate them and wait
so my question is do the private
investigators ever like a run into each
other like if there was like five teams
investigating Odell do they see each
other in car
like waiting two blocks away don't know
that but I mean the one thing I've
always known as far as the private top
picks are always followed I've always
known that ma'am I know Baker may feel
this followed I know all the top five
quitter thank you may feel I just know
they were all followed I had heard a
story that Baker Mayfield basically got
word that he was being followed as he
was out out partying in LA like somebody
told him like hey teams are following
you and he kind of was like okay I'll be
straight narrow then man yeah this goes
on and I've always heard that he's Randy
Moss was followed by the New England
Patriots yes
man I just know just looking for what
behavior I just want to make sure that
it's all good like hey does having like
under the radar crack Pro problem that
we're not knowing about her you know he
can't you know he's married and he's
sleeping with every woman in town or
they're just trying to convey that do
they then sit there with like a Baker
Mayfield or with like a Randy Moss and
like see if they'll admit to something
sure I think so yeah they're definitely
what are other crazy situations you've
heard about I don't know I mean gosh I
don't know I didn't we could ask my dad
I mean I don't know see if he knows but
these are just things I've known and
always known and this is what goes on in
the NFL these are these are billion
dollar owners the investments big
investments the future of their
organization the jobs of these coaches
are going to find a private investigator
with him and get them on here and follow
Fender ik for like a week yeah wouldn't
see much a lot of Survivor clustered if
the Patriots don't trade their powers in
laws by them which positions will they
focus on 23 and 31 if the Patriots don't
trade yeah what do you think they'll
look at 23 and 31 right oh I haven't got
the tackles yet right but yeah our old
line o corner o line and core come on
there's nobody values the corner
position like him right that's part of
the reason I think he's bitter at Malcom
Butler I think it was like part of the
reason I always thought and again I
don't know this again I know people
around the other is that he was probably
mad he didn't take his lowball offer and
that always bothered him you know it's
just the way he is but I would think
corner and I would think there's gonna
be good corners at 23 and 31 because
it's a deep class so corner and ol I I
would say those was two I would look at
and who what else and that maybe that
big [ __ ] from south
that tight end that could be in play if
your chronic retirement right those are
the guys that Penn State popped in my
head ratchet I haven't watched tight
ends yet either so I can't go there yet
but last one final question do you think
Tom Brady liked Brandon cooks came out
today that Brett that Tom Brady was not
sad that Brandon cooks was trading huh
and that he didn't actually fit into the
scheme right but do you think he liked
Brandon cooks I'm sure he liked him I
would think that they explained the
whole situation the Tom and the amount
of money he was maybe asking and
everything in tom was like nah he's not
worth that or whatever it is so he was
okay with it the fact that they know
Julian Edelman is coming back right he's
a similar skill set to a cooked except
cooks is just fade it straight away
faster you still be at the Hogan they
still got what's-his-name that missed a
year last year right alka Mitchell right
so I think they still like him I feel
like Tom Brady is like living and he's
like a grown-ass man he's got kids and
like they met like a couple Heyman
Gisele and they like hung out and then
they're moving and Giselle's like are
you are you upset that our neighbors are
moving he's like no like no new friends
like I've reached this eight I don't get
upset by this anymore it's not a big
deal it shows you where they're at
though at least they're asking Tom
that's good right because there was a
time period where they didn't ask Tom
and Tom wanted to be asked but Tom
didn't also didn't want to show up in
the spring to Train and do all that and
they were like well you're not here how
can you tell us what pyres to play and
you know you're living in California and
only coming in for OTAs that was always
a little struggle there yeah all right
let's give Phil a call because it's two
minutes before he's expected I want two
or three minutes late I think I'm gonna
sit for 15 minutes I don't know I was
told people these PMS is that his
initials Phil couldn't make my son a
second cuz I couldn't give him Barton is
the middle name and make my son pms
initials just not right
can't do it good thought by you right
yeah thanks Chris I'm sure fillable
thank you for that later in life yeah
let's call him that right off the bat
yeah 14 how you doing did your son tell
you for eight for 15 or for 24 15 god he
told us for twice so we were calling you
early PMS PMS
know what we are going to start off
though is with a little game feel called
filling time I have three topics for you
that you don't know what they are I
don't even know what they are what I
think it is something from your era
alright Phil this is the first one
drum roll Josh picks out and Josh what's
our first topic for Phil in time
Raven sign rg3 to a one-year deal I
think is a very good chance he's going
to probably beat out Joe Flacco this
long and I he's man he deserves a
starting job and he'll probably be Joe
Flacco out right away in training camp
[Laughter]
that was for real I just stopped some
people on T you know oh whatever
I won't get into all those people yeah
they're not worth their time
oh my god you know people go on TV and
they literally here's what would bother
me I mean at least I have I don't know
whatever
do you know you're just lying because
that's just to create whatever on TV
right always right we just straight face
in you're lying and you're gonna that
drives me crazy but what do I think hey
if this talent was so good for that one
or two years then it's worth a look yeah
I'll be I'll be very surprised if it
works right
yeah great Roman is the R is the running
coach so he did have Colin Kapernick in
San Francisco so that could help him in
that respect right I mean I got to think
they're just like they're just going
like diamond in the rough right dad I
mean I can't imagine I would think
Baltimore that only two guys have in
their roster right now right or Flacco
and Josh Woodrum no that's a free agent
right
so he might not even be there and I
would think he's really not gonna be but
I was just gonna say like I would think
they were just hoping yeah
to hit the diamond-in-the-rough jackpot
whatever it may be I would I would
expect the Ravens maybe draft a
quarterback in the second or third round
this year and then you have a RG 3 maybe
as a third stringer / experienced backup
as you have somebody else I think the
thing that's interesting is you go back
to last year where they were even
contemplating signing Kaepernick and and
they said to their fan base pray for us
just when they were thinking about
signing Kaepernick and this is like the
bootleg version of Kaepernick that's
already proven thank you
that's already proven in other places
he's not a dime in the rough yeah we've
already seen this yeah so I don't know
if it works well he would be the backup
they'll draft a guy who would end up
being the third one that's what they
really want right and but the debt the
draft there are some sneaky guys to
draft later or whatever you don't the
goal may be in there I know you don't
have to go in the first two SEC around
if I'm drafting I can find one later
that has a chance to be a backup what's
in here right alright next question for
fill-in time let's go to the hats the
Green Bay Packers are turning their
offense back to page one yes according
to head coach Mike McCarthy we've taken
a scrub brush approach to the whole
system scrubbing it away Sims Wow
and they said that when you have the
same offensive system for 12 years and
you're playing late into the playoffs
you usually turn the page evaluate and
just evolve but we're different this
year we're going back to page 1 in the
playbook Oh Phil Simms what do you think
no I don't know I think somebody don't
explain what all that means to me
because you just did a great job of
saying it yeah so I think what they were
doing is they're saying when you're
successful you just kind of build off
that offense but because it wasn't
successful we're gonna re-evaluate our
entire offense is what it's others say
yeah go ahead well there we go
okay I want to say I remember covering
the Green Bay Packers
I remember watch them beat the
pittsburgh steelers down in dallas in
the Super Bowl and they were doing one
thing we're chucking that ball down the
field Aaron Rodgers threw about six
passes of that game you know that were
six of the all-time best throws and
Superbowl yes I mean just missiles I
mean yeah I think that won the game down
the middle down in Long James Jones
would that be right yes yes right down
the middle
yep perfect coverage and he just threw a
[ __ ] 103 mile-per-hour fastball over
the outside corner he said to me once
why do you think Brett Favre through
that best I said because Billy thought
he could get it in there yes and that
was there Rodgers I loved that offense
but and and then I course done many of
their games and you know what Mike
McCarthy says I'm just trying to find as
many ways to throw seams and do this and
that that I can for Aaron Rodgers but
they definitely course got away from
that offense big-time as years went on
yeah I mean that's what it seems like it
seems like they're basically saying like
hey I've been listening to that Sims and
left no podcast and that sends guys been
[ __ ] on my offense so maybe they
will change some of our routine basics I
don't know Mike McCarthy a you know he's
a pretty cool dude really he really is I
know he is I don't even say that you
don't think McCarthy listens to the you
know they say by Green Bay after the
football game there's not much to do so
maybe they say well what the hell we got
nothing else to do all right one more
fill for you the final question of this
week's edition of filling time bear vs.
lion
staple fill it's been an argument that
me and your son have had for a long time
if an African lion and a grizzly bear
got into a fight which one would win let
me give you some statistics an African
lion is about six foot one and weighs
about 250 pounds an African lion is not
6:1 and I'm talking about in length okay
and they're not two hundred five hundred
pounds
not right a bear grizzly bear when they
stand up is about seven eight and they
weigh about 600 to 700 pounds so does a
male lion I don't know what I'm not
enough out of you don't let them know
what side you're on Phil actually you
know what Phil I want you to listen to
Chris's argument and then I'm gonna
argue to Chris give Phil your argument
for the African lion
well the African life first of all I
mean our narrator here is giving some
horrible frickin stats okay because I'm
a male lion can be anywhere from 400 to
650 pounds okay hey it's only a male
lion with like the sharpest claws on
earth oh yeah and like the biggest
things on earth oh yeah and it's also
one of the greatest athletes and pure
power muscle packed protein punch that
you've never seen before and a bear it's
just a big fat thing of blubber okay
interesting that eats I don't know nuts
and berries and sometimes some meat and
then sleeps are the other six months you
trap that line into a corner cuz the
Lions gonna run cuz he's very smart he's
gonna go I'm just gonna survive there's
no point in me fighting this big fat
[ __ ] bear right but if you trap him in
the corner
yeah he's gonna go [ __ ] I'm trapped I'm
gonna beat the [ __ ] out of you bear yeah
that's interesting
alright over me this time I'm going to
keep going here we go first of all they
both use their claws and teeth so I'm
gonna say that it's even right it's very
rare that you get that but I want to say
this Lions oh they have a mane and it
protects their neck great bears have
that protection all over with the thick
fur and the body fat oh and you're
saying that they hibernate guess what my
mind he's well rested lions maybe you
should get some more sleep
bears weigh about 2 to 3 times more than
a lion Lions typically hunt in packs
that means that the bear is ready for
that one-on-one he's what I like to call
the Quintin nelson of that's my freakin
I may be a professional and then lastly
I'm gonna say this back in European
courts there were records of them
training bears to fight lions in case
they got crazy so the Bears were the
last line of defense which in my mind
big Phil means that they're the
that if necessary destroy the lion let
me hear what you got to say what's the
verdict very good arguments by both
sides thank you know and now I know Mike
McCarthy why in the hell would he want
to live you know you make a great
argument I know you really believe this
and everything but I'm going with you
Adam yes so Adam I agree with you right
because if the lion were to bite into
the bear and let's say he's going the
bear can then just start clubbing the
crap out of the line I see them do that
all the time I know is the lion has
protection around the neck the bear he's
got six he's got about two feet of
blubber you've got to get through before
you could even hurt him Chris are you
going to take the judge's ruling or will
you send this to the appellate court it
screwed this judge he's got no authority
in this court by the week or the week we
sell this yeah my gripe of the week you
know Josh Rosen is just so smart you
know you have to really challenge him
intellectually that's what's really
gonna be the problem with NFL coaches
okay now let's throw a line we got this
one play yeah and it suppose he'll be
intellectually challenged every day
right I don't care man what uh what did
I tell you so many people on TV are
saying it well you know you're gonna
challenge him intellectually what do you
think these guys are that are coaching
these NFL players hell he should be on
Wall Street making you know hundreds of
millions instead of supper with a bunch
of idiots trying to coach them
I love it all right way to go you the
man Phil you nailed it the week that was
a good thought all right see dad be good
[Applause]
how you feeling I mean I don't know I'm
more of the expert on animals I don't
really care I've watched this we are
going to girl I'm gonna set up a movie
theater I'm gonna write it my house and
we're just gonna watch on loop lion vs.
bear but you I didn't like how you your
stats on the line we're so wrong I mean
listen you tried to make it into a
female lion that's what you tried to do
the male lion can be anywhere from 500
to 600 pounds interesting that's good
other question about the Packers sure
Mike McCarthy and Joe Philbin even if
they erase the playbook if you're not
the right guy to redo the playbook then
does it matter that you've turned back
together no I know that's that's like it
goes back to my old saying it was like
you know how I say sometimes like they
don't even know what they don't know
like you got to have somebody else in
there to go oh no I was with McDaniels
or McVeigh or Shanahan or Payton and we
did it this way or we package these
plays together or we read this guy on
this play and you're reading it wrong or
whatever it may be
yeah now if I don't they bring in Rogers
for his insight you know I'd like them
to go what kind of plays do you think
they do more it's a start it's a start
right
ran going you know what we need to do
some more we do you have to do
something's different
I love it all right so we have a few
more things to get to let's go to our
favorite quotes of the week vendrick's
gonna reach in here and he's gonna pull
out the first were sweating at the start
of the dad interview I mean your
forehead was glistening oh that's what I
really wanted to talk about well I'm a
one-man band Chris I'm doing on
Josh Cardinals trainer buddy Morris is
tired of personal trainers and social
media
the Cardinals trainer left go I got to
pull that man I have I'm writing it
notes for you I got it right there all
right quote today it wasn't great I saw
some things that make me want to go home
and drink heavily seeing some of our
skill guys dragging fatigue is always
gonna be a factor in everything I'm not
a fan of personal terrorists
he calls personal trainers personal
terrorists I'm to the point now I'd
rather have players do nothing because
you have to correct everything this is
the Cardinals trainer still talking also
not a fan of social media it's ruin the
country so when my guys walk into their
personal terrorist Facebook snapchat
Twitter Instagram that stuff is
ridiculous
and according to the left goes research
here buddy Morris also does not like
wearing shoes the last thing about
social media I don't that wasn't even it
wasn't he was just on a rant about
personal trainers and was like by the
way you know what else sucks Millennials
so when my guys walk into their personal
terrorist Facebook snapchat Twitter
Instagram that stuff is ridiculous
that makes that's this amazing about
strength coaches talk to me about the
creatures that are strengths oh gosh
they're just because when I found out
that Gruden's kid we've seen pictures of
them stuff he's the strength coach yeah
there's a screw loose there's almost a
little bit like a screw loose in a good
way right like it's never meanness but
it's like meat headedness definitely
some off the radar hot takes or you're
like where did he come up with this
thought and why is he yelling this out
to everybody in the waiver remember
instantly I mean gosh my strength coach
you know at Texas I had mad dog who was
like at one point like Dean in the
United States record holder of the bench
press right now yeah it was like 500
pound bench press I mean the Alabama
strength coach is infamous for his
yelling but what was Mad Dog was I mean
we were the king of the chants we had
more chance what were some examples ah
yeah it's on baby
ooh and you guys are yelling this while
you're doing work no party like a long
home party cuz a long home party don't
stop say what and you would do this when
I mean before the game after work
we were all we had more chance and [ __ ]
but that was him do some more chances we
used to have a thing before as we were
stretching we went through all the
positions right so it was like kind of a
way to get some energy into practice and
you'd have to go through they'd be like
you know he'd go roll coal and he go or
B's touchdown makers wide or cubies
let's see what our B's ankle breakers
cubies touchdown Makos and then if it's
like you went through the whole you know
are you reacting to it you know elby's
jawbone break us oh man we'd like screw
it up we'd like chop it up - so the
quarterbacks one day we Diego's chop it
up to a biack touchdown and then but the
other thing I love about this is to me
it all goes to the issue with the
Patriots yeah
with his private trainer and all that
stuff right and I know one everyone's
talking about the personal trainers oh
isn't this great you get another mind in
there these team trainers yeah the fact
that he's calling personal trainers
personal terrorists there is a battle
going on that no one's talking about
yeah which is the team strength guy
right and the personal strength guy it's
a real thing in the NFL because a lot of
times the strength coach in the NFL
there's nothing he can do a little bit
he's all stuck right this guy thing is
son of money old guard yeah he's seen as
the dumb jock goes push wait and these
guys are like we're gonna have you do
biometric stretching that gets the
insular part of your manga the kale
smoothie while you're at your write that
drives them crazy now I will say that
there are strength coaches in the NFL
that are a little outdated and can use a
little technology maybe it's the guy
that doesn't wear words and wear shoes
and doesn't like someone I mean the guy
I had in garrard gman
and Tampa who's now in Pittsburgh I mean
he was the man he had more quotes and
things and he had a cup at the front of
his desk that how about a nice cup of
shut the [ __ ] up like basically to let
you know like you know I'm the boss
around here so that's what was on his
bed was on his window in his desk right
so like how about a nice cup of shut the
[ __ ] up
I mean the guy Waterson I had an in
Tennessee
I mean ultimate prankster muscle head
meathead if you were new to the team he
might come up to you and do push-ups
naked like out of nowhere in the locker
room like what Oh headstand push-ups
just to make you uncomfortable front of
you in front of you like what you're
right they're getting changed because
he's just gonna see like what kind of
guys I'm gonna be suddenly he goes up to
Dion Lewis the free-agent goes hey do ya
like handstand once to like hand say
Busch Jeff this is the same guy in
Tennessee that he is I gotta tell this
I'm sorry we're on this talk no for I
don't we're gonna make this a two hour
podcast is he Courtland Finnegan in him
had a little back in force I saw this I
think I told the story about the
ping-pong balls and all that stuff
Reba's I it was so he put popcorn he
filled up then against car with popcorn
the strange car the whole car like
packed to the top like to where you're
on top of the the sunroof like dumping
into the branch right so he does that
Courtland is on a mission to get him
back Courtland like a few days later
decides to do it to his office and fills
the entire like to like waist high in
his office of popcorn water sends a
psycho he shows up at the facility like
4:00 a.m. so he gets there and he sees
it he's go I'm not gonna let this little
[ __ ] get over on me and in this is all
in good love he had a friend who worked
in some you know big leading company
exactly and he got over there and they
brought an industrial vacuum and just
clean I ran he Courtland the next day is
he comes in the facility and he's
watching Watterson and he's so excited I
haven't been to my office yeah and
Courtland can't wait and he's gonna
follow him in and he walks in there and
Watterson walks out spotless clean he's
fantastic
what the I mean Courtland was like blown
away like what good chef how did this
happen pays to have connections in town
yes tomorrow that's right he would know
everything if you were at the club or
whatever he knew people so again
probably people tailing right
next quote Robert Quinn recently traded
out of Los Angeles says I am NOT a West
Coast guy put it that way oh you want me
to read yeah I can do that where am I
looking on the page here up there it is
per Armando Salguero Quinn called the
move a breath of fresh air adding that
he was quote suffocating with the Rams
quote I'm not a West Coast guy put it
that way and quote I feel like any time
someone leaves someplace they're like
I'm not really a New York guy I'm not
really a West Coast guy what does he
mean by I'm not a West Coast guy put it
like that like what does that mean are
you insulting no one believes your
insults of LA justify his move trying to
give himself a silver lining like what
does that mean I'm not a West Coast guy
I mean listen I'm not a West Coast guy
Joe I just I believe I'm a I am a my
mold of my personality fits the East
Coast but am in if I got stuck in a
laid-back ha damn too bad I got stuck
here I mean that would be one of the
places I'd want to get stuck I'm saying
yeah I mean it certainly wouldn't want
to be like oh I can't stand living in
California no San Francisco and LA would
be towards the top of the list and
cities I was on to live in Bleach
reporter sent me know later where's
Quinn from do we know I want to say he's
like fine as he and North Carolina kid
he did go to North Carolina I feel like
he's from somewhere in there but maybe
I'm wrong pull the teams pull but I mean
I get that but yeah don't take shots the
city as a whole like yeah okay he's not
even taking shots of Carolina I'm not
really a West Coast guy yeah I don't
know man sign me up after this winter I
am ready for it last quote here oh
there's another tell me he like me
that's st. Louis more than he did with
the LA Rams I'm saying final quote here
Johnny Manziel talking about his
experience with X's and O's during a
visit to the Dan Patrick show Manziel
said quote if Cleveland did any of their
homework they would have known I wasn't
a guy who came in every day and watched
the film quote I wasn't a guy who really
knew the X's and O's of football end
quote
that is such a ridiculous quote and it
only gets better from there
go ahead Pro Football Talk took the
quote right wrote an article and then
Manziel tweeted the following to
article right quote draft a quarterback
in the first round and put him in a
toxic quarterback room versus what it
was like my second year with McCown
completely different situation it's all
about the right fit and mine in
Cleveland wasn't right that's just the
facts I also have nobody to blame but
myself who was in that room the first
year that he was drafted him Brian Hoyer
and who else'll we miss it was the Jose
Kyle Shanahan
so that was a toxic or so I guess so I
guess it's it's Brian Hoyer because Kyle
Shannon was there year two also right
yeah with McCown uh he wasn't that was
the year I think he left McHale let he
didn't have McGowan
gotcha yeah so he's saying that Kyle
Shanahan and Brian Hoyer was a toxic
room but you know from a lot of people
in the Browns that that doesn't make
sense and not even Kyle I mean
definitely no I don't even know where to
start with this subject I mean again
okay let me start while you yeah go
ahead I'm gonna say this right Manziel
I'm seeing a trend here and I'm gonna
put this out there plain and I'm
probably gonna get some blowback and I'm
okay with that
I am noticing in media right now
everyone cuddling up to Johnny Manziel
because they want to be aligned with the
cool guy right I know I'm not even
talking about the Odell's and LeBrons
and the Drake's and all that stuff every
time Manziel goes somewhere it's man
we're rooting for you and stuff as a
human being I am rooting for Johnny
Manziel to get over the things that he
is battling right now as a football
player I am done I'm done so what one
you're gonna come out there and say you
weren't for the exes knows if they did
their research when you spent that
entire draft process saying that you
were dedicated to football and you were
a warrior and obsessed with this sport
right and then the fact that I'm seeing
every single thing that he ends with
right now going I also have nobody to
blame but myself after he goes and
blames a toxic room of an offensive
coordinator and another quarterback he
is using I only have myself to blame as
the new just be
honest just being honest guy is my least
favorite guy in the world hey by the way
your shirts disgust and just being
honest you can't just throw that after
and make it okay I feel like right now
Manziel is using the whole I only have
myself to blame as the just being honest
after he's blaming people I I understand
that people deserve second chances I
don't know though if I really care and
he went into a thing last week about
Kaepernick and he didn't want to be
compared to Kaepernick anymore because
Kaepernick is doing great things but
here's the problem Johnny Manziel you
are getting second chances and he's not
and all the things that you did was
yourself to blame
Kaepernick is standing up for these
things and I'm looking at Johnny and I'm
going man we're we are really willing to
give this guy a second chance and trot
him out there the Texas A&M pro day and
trot him out there at the San Diego
State I don't want to do cf felonies
getting all these opportunities
meanwhile he's the one that's booked in
the GMA interview where he wants to
divulge all the things that he's
battling I just feel like I'm in this
this mix right here where I'm seeing a
guy calling out people and then saying
it's just myself to blame and then I'm
at a point where I can't honestly
discuss him because he says they DS a
substance abuse issue and in our country
when you go through that it's only
polite to let him battle that himself
but I am not seeing the actions of
someone that is feeling remorse I'm
seeing that someone that's willing to
throw flames and then go but I went
through a lot and I got and most of the
blame goes on me yeah right sit back
you're tweeting he tweeted that that was
he said this was not an interview was
not a surprise question he decided to
call a quarterback room toxic yeah it
just dies higher he was like like truly
a boy scout the Patriots wanted Brian
Hoyer because they knew he would get
along well with Tom Brady I'm just not
seeing your actions your words and your
follow-ups making any sense I think
that's really where you say it I mean
first of all I mean you know I mean most
people in the NFL did know Johnny didn't
do [ __ ] and didn't study football that's
why
Cleveland was crazy for drafting him in
the first round that's why he was there
and picked 23 or 25 whatever it may be
right and they had a GM at the time ray
farmer who yeah I'm just saying he was
completely clueless clueless mean
clueless that's all I can say to that so
he took a run on it why because he was
Johnny Manziel and his highlight tape
looked good but I can tell you that
there was coordinators there and I'm
pretty sure Kyle didn't have a
first-round grade on them if I remember
correctly so but to say it's toxic I
mean it makes me mad cuz it makes it
sound like he's like almost attacking
Kyle right to where okay yeah these
concerns were out there they were real
but then you also tried like you said
fool everybody to go yes oh I'm
professional and huddle around and I'm
gonna tell all you coaches and owners
everybody know I'm a pro now and I'm
really focused and here's how the
workouts gonna go so some people took
you out their words so now you're gonna
get mad at those people for taking you
at your word you know so I don't know
it's a little all over the place
I do appreciate his honesty but yes it's
like he's taking accountability with
also blaming at the same time to a
degree and I think that's what I don't
like I mean yeah I I you know I I can
remember conversations with Kyle that
year where he was like oh I mean if I
had to throw Johnny Manziel and the on
the field I'm not sure he would really
be able to call the plays or run the
offense or do that type of right so you
know can you tell the story about
Johnny's touchdown drive in Buffalo no
the one in it was in Buffalo they were
playing it was in Buffalo he came in
towards the end of the game right and he
said he scored a touchdown but I do know
that that's when Kyle had realized like
oh okay this guy doesn't know the whole
playbook quite the way he should and
yeah Kyle had to they had a break the
huddle and I know Kyle had to say things
to him in his helmet to basically remind
him of the play or look at this guy or
throw to this guy or whatever it was so
those guys gonna do this this other guys
gonna do this right throw just read this
this week safety if he does this throw
it to him or if he does that throw it to
that guy but yeah all those concerns
were there I mean it also to understand
when you're trying to make a comeback if
you come out and say I'm not really an
X's and O's guy there's two things to
football
there's knowing the place and reading a
defense with how those plays are gonna
react right and physically throwing the
ball so if you're not going to study the
playbook and yet you're telling us that
you're working as hard as you can to get
another shot
who's gonna take on the chance when the
guy that doesn't do X's knows he's got
to go to Canada and just prove himself
nobody's gonna give him a shot in the
NFL okay that's the way it is if he gets
in the NFL there's gonna be riots in the
street what do you mean because it'd
just be an absolute joke if he gets in
the NFL and like a guy like Colin
Kaepernick's not in it it's an
absolutely I think it's a joke that rg3
is on a team in Kaepernick yeah I get
you I get you I mean I understand that
so because what your dad said I'm
surprised of Johnny Manziel is getting
blackballed by the NFL like legitimately
like you know just as much as I said
like maybe League memos go out every now
and then like I wouldn't be shocked if a
leaked memo went out around the NFL is
like don't sign Johnny Manziel because
it's gonna cause this this and this to
happen yeah and they're not gonna be
able to offend it but you know listen
again Johnny Manziel all those warnings
were there all those signals were there
we knew he was a party boy you knew he
just went down to Texas Texas A&M from
everything you hear was I mean Johnny
Manziel was done at Texas A&M whether he
liked it or not he left for the NFL
Draft from what I've been told through
coaches there and things that the Texas
A&M was done with him after that year no
matter what they had enough they felt
like he was ruining their football
program yeah I just thought all that
coming out I was like I can't believe
he's saying that yeah I got a little
intense yeah I want to calm down okay
let's do a new segment call a mood left
go stole his neighbor's Wall Street
Journal and once Simms his reaction on
big stories
federal prosecutors first went up
vendrick
high chair high-end dining that's right
high chair high-end dining right in a
life and art segment top restaurants are
now catering to young foodies and their
parents with sophisticated children's
menu forget chicken fingers and fries
restaurants now want to serve children
prosciutto wrapped grapes and little
mini filet mignons Sims your thoughts
it's good to see they're expanding their
horizons ok I did not think that's a
good some good healthy snacks and yeah
there's certain restaurants where I do
look at the kid menu and I'm like damn
this is a nice restaurant are we really
just giving chicken and fries to the
kids like that's for a little ridiculous
so I don't know about the prosciutto and
grapes like my little my wife is of
course 100% Sicilian she would give that
kind of craft to my little boy and he
would eat it yeah he'll do it so it was
if you were a little kid Oh what phil
simms was taking out my dad where is the
whole basket of bread in the butter and
I'm just gonna eat that that's all I'm
connected
all right next one in left go stole his
neighbor's Wall Street Journal and once
Simms is reaction oh boy this is a good
one cut surprise topic Goddard Sims you
have one minute left go stop the clock
it was not for The Wall Street Journal
Sims you have one minute to talk about
Goddard and the environment on your mark
get set go
gosh you're catching me off guard here
but Stephen Goddard okay he's a guy that
basically is a blogger that continually
fights against what the real science of
the world is out there and he's the
publisher of real science which I find
hilarious first of all first of all this
guy he went to school for electric
engineering and geology which is study
of the rocks which studying of the rocks
can certainly help with some of the at
Missouri's he say it but my big problem
is again he's a climate change denier
but again it's like a lot of people in
this country we love to make qualifying
statements even though we're unqualified
to make them and that's what this guy
would be I mean he has an alias Tony
Heller I mean so that just tells you
he's a shady bullcrap of a person 20
seconds and let's just leave it to the
people that are actually climate
scientists and actually study the air
and see the gas I mean Stephen Goddard
you know again 10 seconds he and he's
just steering he's going to hell you're
going to hell cuz you're steering the
country in the wrong direction because
he's being paid by somebody in the
Republican Party or gas and oil to push
this false message and I've just had
enough of it at times okay I cannot deal
with it I didn't think you were coming
there with that so I was not prepared
for that you did amazing
you did good amazing but I mean gosh I
just don't understand it I just I'm so
sick of hearing like billionaire rich
people or just like rich white people
that think they know all the answers of
the world talk about subjects like if I
have one more Wall Street or come up to
me and tell me about who should be
drafted first at quarterback I don't go
to them like you know I watched Nasdaq
today and you should buy this stock I
watched it I saw it on the screen just
like you did shut the book up I study
this [ __ ] sorry
that's good that was almost two minutes
okay good job it deserved it it's really
good people love what you got good last
one for left go stole his neighbor's
Wall Street Journal let's make a better
world the 24-hour challenge I don't even
know what this is Sims have you heard of
the 24-hour challenge I feel like I have
but I don't know what this is I had it
but it was on the front page of The Wall
Street Journal and it is apparently
apparently short of actual adventures
teens and 20-somethings are sneaking
into change stores and restaurants
including McDonald's Walmart Chucky
Cheese and IKEA staying all night and
posting videos online as evidence what
do you think of this new trend sweeping
the nation
no it makes me extremely concerned about
our nation attorney Amanda what would
what are you kidding me people are
sleeping in tools and Chucky's cheese is
there a more disgusting dirty place to
spend a night asleep
oh let me sleep here sleeping or do you
think they're like messing around the
skee-ball machine so bring it on the
flag reads a skit that picks up the
French fries this is amazing holy cow
your kids like Chuckie Cheese they don't
really I don't think they listen to my
oldest has been doing it in one of the
other states we lived in Phillip has not
been doing Chuckie Cheese nobody else
they get McDonald's occasionally I will
bring
to eat the fries got it that's about it
and they get a toy when they go her now
it depends it depends how much of a
little punk Phillips me I think hiding
in a McDonald's or a Chucky Cheese and
all that stuff sounds really cool you're
gonna play all the games you're gonna
eat all the food until you realize that
none of the games are turned on none of
the food is there and you're not gonna
want to eat it anyway and then you're
gonna get tired and you do I have full
five more hours of this I'm thinking we
do a pot from a Chucky Cheese maybe
24-hour cool you want to do it simple
let's do a 24-hour challenge at Sims oh
he's still on Steven got her it's a
Wikipedia page just scrolling both
seriously who has an alias like that's
what you know like if you have a
pseudonym name named Cody Holly that
means like both the news to God's aunt
the lef koe man let's move on it is time
to talk the NFL Draft
get there hop hold me back I don't wanna
Ella getting me out of me look Fenric
was the first one to curse I didn't
curse alright so I want to do I'm gonna
linebackers quickly okay wait we're not
doing linebackers I was just gonna do we
don't have enough time are we doing DBS
or linebackers so linebackers will be on
Monday oh here we go producers we
promised the third linebacker the first
round but guess what that's coming up on
Monday linebackers we really caught us
about the linebackers though stop we're
doing corner I know but I'm just saying
ably we haven't we didn't talk about
them at all not really
I for some reason there's a part of me
that thinks we at least talked about ro
Quan Smith and Jermaine Edmonds they're
just we just literally have said their
name on five different podcasts but
haven't talked about alright so maybe we
should do them no we're doing corridors
corners a great combo all right so
here's what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
read let's not make this 45 minutes okay
so I'm gonna read the quick breakdown of
the corner and we're gonna start off
with Denzel Ward because he has
perceived by many to be the number one
corner yes and our good friend Brett
Threlkeld gave in my Instagram DMS
unsolicited his breakdown of Denzel wort
and he started off with this Denzel Ward
is overrated I'm interested to see what
Simms has to say and I said
give me the breakdown he goes superior
athlete extremely fast 510 plays a lot
longer than that even tons of experience
with man coverage most of the time he's
easily able to catch up make a play on
the fly because he can cut up because of
his athleticism tremendous ability to
put himself in a position to make a play
but he isn't so good at finding the ball
good receivers make catches when he's
right in their face but Ward face guards
the whole time overall I think he's
easily a first-round talent on
athleticism alone but I don't think his
techniques or its polishes everyone
thinks which technique can easily be
taught in the NFL also didn't see him
play zone a lot what do you think of
Brett Threlkeld evaluation I think that
wasn't very good evaluate what great
what round grade would you give of his
evaluation oh that's a first-round
reverse round great Brett way to go
alright so don't say the same stuff just
give your overall sense all teams don't
give first or second round grades you
give a you have a grading system right
gotcha right so here are some Slough
goats around grade what should I gave
her all on Denzel okay I think that our
man there hit a lot of the good points I
mean he really did I mean he's he's a
phenomenal man-to-man cover guy he
really is I mean he's got the ability
like a let's just say a generous Jenkins
Jason Barret as far as just mirroring
receivers staying in their hip pocket
his change of direction
his ability to you know be effortless
and also efficient out of transition
right like backpedal extra steps to
right forward know he can put his foot
in the ground and come forward how does
he compare to the top quarterback in
last year Lattimore he's not as good as
either Ohio State corner from ash no he
is not
and he lacks that size and I think the
main point that our buddy made there too
that's concerning to me like I like this
kid this film was really good but he's
not my favorite corner in the whole
draft no he's not my favorite boy just I
don't I don't trust things about this
guy and I think it goes back to what our
buddy told us Brett his coverages he's
all over guys but he never makes a play
on the ball I mean never and he very
rarely really makes a play where you go
oh we almost picked it so you're not can
we hash break up no it's a little bit
like almost like a Ronald Darby was a
few years ago where we said man it's
great coverage but there's never a play
on the football interesting and that
bothers me a little bit I think he's
gonna be amazing in the slot i yeah his
body bothers me a little bit because I
do you think sense against some of the
bigger receivers in the NFL yeah he is
gonna have little issues like that
he's twitchy he's smooth he's effortless
I mean I wrote this at the end I wrote
kid is really good I just said I don't
love him but you can't argue with his
coverage skills they're legit
his body is biggest negative plays small
and lacks length and strength in my in
my opinion at the end of the day all
right so is he the first-round pick
oh yes yeah he's not he's not like I saw
him mock today that said he was like
number 7 to the Tampa Bay Buccaneers I
would have a hard time picking a corner
like this at number 7 I'll understand it
yeah but I just write I wrote also don't
think he placed a 4 3 speed for 3 speed
for 3 to speed don't get me wrong he's
fast
real good player but I said he was
somewhere between like 20 and 32 love it
so that's where I was all right the next
one this is of Josh Jackson and it is
from a really good friend Mitch Neeson
yeah who drove four hours to the
Superbowl to deliver his Iowa package
what up buddy
I eat look Mitch I'm gonna be real with
you bro sent me a lot of info I'm gonna
go to the overall though I wanted
overall but man I'm telling you this guy
he's broken down strengths he's broken
down weaknesses he lists his shrinks as
ball hawk ability mere ability play
recognition he Lissa's weaknesses at
speed tackling at run games it's a full
Iowa scouting pack it's amazing I love
Mitch but his overall thing is
first-round maybe top 15 for only being
a one-year starter and two-star recruit
coming out of high school his
development between his sophomore year
in junior was night and day
concerns are he has ability to press and
play man consistency I truly believe he
can play man coverage because I've seen
enough plays where he performs well
Jackson will thrive with a strong run
defense and a good middle of the field
safety that alone attacked the ball he's
four five six 40-yard dash was quite
underwhelming speed concerns but he does
see him as a mid round first rounder do
you like Mitch's scouting report I think
there's some Goods and some bats what
are the goods
well the goods I mean his his talk about
playing the football his size those
things are all admirable I mean what did
he miss all right so this would be one
of the guys like first I've seen some of
the MOX like everybody's
I'm in the top 20 like there's no this
kids a a borderline I don't think he's a
first-round draft pick oh wow this kid
to me is a total scheme fit and and and
our buddy what's his name here Mitch
Mitch he kind of said it he just has to
read his own work a little bit yeah it's
really hard for me to ever go he did say
he's gonna need a good run defense he
can kind of float around I don't know
about his top-end speed and I don't know
about him in man demand yeah he hasn't
seen him play man but he believes he can
play man right so that's an issue for me
you're not a legit now if I can go you
can play man-to-man a time out yeah we
said this with Desmond King sure at Iowa
Testament Kings been really good for the
Chargers yet a good scheme fit right but
Desmond King was more of a slot safety
guy this is an outside corner all the
way you see Josh Jackson has a non
first-round pick corner Oh without a
doubt I don't think you're really
comfortable yeah I do not see there's no
way I'm making Josh Johnson one of my
picks in the first round there's a lot
of ways this is Quincy Wilson this is T
stay board from last year the Florida
kids that had great size that are
underwhelming and man-to-man coverage
and don't have the split foot speed to
play against the legit NFL receivers now
left Seattle or somebody at the end of
the first round was like he's a scheme
fitting but maybe your San Francisco and
right right Los Angeles but I just don't
see it at the end of the day and still
even Seattle and those teams are
learning like we hit the play man-to-man
sometimes we can't play cover three
press bail because teams are figuring it
out but okay plays a lot of zone
coverage definitely okay he's an
impressive looking guy he has maybe the
best ball skills out of all these guys
to catch it like a receiver and some of
his interceptions are like they're
amazing highlight reel one-handed
catches whatever they may be all that
but he does play a ton of zone zone
coverage I'm not impressed with
necessarily his ability his
straight-ahead burst is underwhelming
his ability to turn and run and go to
that extra gear that's gonna be a
trouble against top number one receivers
in the NFL he's not gonna be able to run
with them he's a little clunky and slow
footed too in and out of transition it's
not horrible for a big guy but I didn't
watch and go ooh that's pretty special
for that size right there you know does
not as tackle as well as you would like
you think they're being someone that big
especially being from Iowa Kirk French
seems like a balichek disciple yeah
so there was those issue didn't you know
it was not good in space from that
opinion so overall so I'm just cuz our
idea while straight straight versus good
it's not special side to side movements
clunky but if it gets his in his hands
he's gonna catch it he has ball skills
he would really scare me if he had to
play man-to-man verse good NFL wide
receivers holds a ton when he has to
play man-to-man he is a walking pass
interference call and then does not
tackle as well as you expect not as
physical as you would think either and
not very good at breaking people down in
space and making those tackles hands are
amazing smart smart sure yes because
you're not gonna beat him on the same
route over and over he's gonna catch on
but I just wrote not a first-round
quarter cornerback in my opinion total
scheme fit doesn't do anything physical
elite and we've talked about this for
years the best round is about physically
elite miss and I don't say that times up
that was good okay how do you feel I
feel good I mean there's a lot of like
them out there so right now yeah the two
perceived as like two of the top corners
you have them graded a lot lower than
they actually are
you have Denzel more in the 15 yeah and
you have Josh Jackson the second I love
this okay I'll clarify with this like
Josh I feel yes he's not a first-round
corner Denzel I can see people's
argument he's just not my love affair
guys right okay does that make sense
Sondra procedure that means we are next
on this list
Carlton Davis of Auburn right Carlton
Davis was reviewed by Colin Vidal on
Twitter and okay I'll call you Colin he
says Carlton Davis is a tall athletic
build long arms allows him to have a
strong jab at the line of scrimmage when
he hits you he can lock you up and knock
you off your route good but not great
speed but can stick it to man and his
long frame can he helps him make up
space I'd say second he literally wrote
to Rd so either meant second or third I
don't know because he's more scheme
specific for a press Bale team reminds
me of Richard Sherman but that's a lofty
comparison can't wait to see what sim
says Sims what do you think about
Collins analysis of Carlton Davis yeah I
think this is one of the surprises of
the draft to me right here this kid this
kid's special I think no no
so what do you think of Collins break
Johnson's breakdown is pretty good I
think there's a few things that maybe
we're missing they're all like I
understand his scheme fit he has those
type of measurable as to where you go he
fits that pressure because he's got
incredible length he's got incredible
swag I really like this kid he what are
you seeing on film he's just cocky he
throws his body around he talks [ __ ] he
plays the position I would want people
that talk you know that is right so so
we look around let me hear ya what for
what round do you think well I think
this kid is a hands-down first round
corner I think he's somewhere 15 to 30
to I wrote if you're on the board then
you're taking Carlton Davis over Denzel
wort he would be my type of guy more and
for my team I would rather have this guy
and certainly would rather have him over
Josh Jackson that's not even thought to
me the we're not hearing about this guy
in the first round I don't really
understand it Wow I mean he's the better
version of Josh Jackson and he plays on
the island a lot during the game he can
play man-to-man this kid this kid to me
was I brought in a lot of ways I thought
I understand the Richard Sherman
comparisons yeah another guy I wrote I
go he's a he's a better coverage
all-around player than Artie Byrnes was
Marty Burns is probably a little bit
faster straightaway sure this guy's
change of direction skills transition
skills already burn playing ball right
the way he can tackle this kid he has
potential later in his career to play
safety this kid so that's where I also
will play into this but let me just get
into a few of my lines here about 20
seconds yeah but I was really impressed
with his man-to-man skills Auburn Auburn
trust him they trust him on an island
more than the Iowa kid or the Colorado
kid I wrote the kid is legit I really
like him first round hips are good
bursts as good as you watch he plays the
ball really well he's physical nothing
goes uncontested yeah and I'll I wrote I
like him more than burns coming out I
like a more than Eli Apple I wrote who's
this 10th pick of the draft his ability
of the line of scrimmage is really
[ __ ] good and then I wrote Zuerlein
said he's rich Sherman and I wrote I get
that maybe better he's got better feet
than Richard Sherman though I wrote so
there you go
that was really good yeah so right now
if you're ranking the three we've done
you would go Carlton Davis Denzel Ward
and then Josh Jackson yes
I like it a lot all right next yes and I
understand if somebody out there goes oh
I like Denzel Ward better I get that I
understand the guy that fancies me yeah
I like Carlton Davis he's like [ __ ]
talkers next up is not like the size and
measurables next up is Isaiah Oliver
right and this one was reviewed by Brian
her knee okay he says that Isaiah our
Oliver is a long armed quarter who be
perfect for a prick so everyone's saying
you should almost Group these guys
together there really are that similar
they're all in that mold of player where
you go it's this is the bigger Longer
corner okay but Brian finish nobody
seems to get away from him if he gets
his hands on them cannot emphasize
enough how well he tracks the ball in
the air on deep routes both of his picks
this year came on plays down the field
he has some breathing room if he is
beaten because of how long he is and I
would say he's got good enough straight
in speed but not elite love the fact he
was a former wide receiver and switched
to corner after his freshman year I
would not say he's anything special when
it comes to tackling but he's willing to
put his body out there played some
special teams specifically returning
punts struggled in zone D when he has
off the line
tends to get caught look in the
backfield and zone also tends to focus
on deep routes or what is in front of
him he seems to get beat most often on
intermediate routes worried about him
getting against quicker receivers lack
short area quickness and the hips but he
couldn't really run down the field wall
on a post overall he's a scheme fit
corner I think he goes in the second or
of a team falls in love maybe in the
first PS give as much constructive
criticism as possible looking for advice
to get better at writing reports thank
you no I like it I think he said a lot a
lot of very good points really well even
Brian I'm giving this guy though I said
and what are you giving Brian's right I
think that was a pretty that was that
was first-round caliber oh good job
Brian I'm not even saying it's all right
but all three guys have at least made
points to support their stuff which I
like but I'll say this okay a lot of the
things he said he is he's a tall long
Seattle scheme fit he does play the ball
down the well right uh but like our
buddy said there I mean he gets beat on
intermediate routes well that's because
he's not very good with short area
quickness or area transit so he was
totally right and there's no really
burst when he turns and
or puts his foot in the ground and goes
oh I'm backpedaling let me break on this
out route and do some there's nothing
there so what was your grew year round
projection I said second early third day
he's now taking your fourth spot yeah
because you would have a heart attack if
you said oh this kid's got a cover
Antonio Brown forty snaps in a game
you'd go well he's gonna I mean Antonio
Brown is gonna fake the slant and come
out and have nine hundred yards so then
where do you use a guy in today's NFL
that's not good at Short area quickness
yeah well again it's gonna be a zone
scheme type of fit so him versus Marvin
Jones is a matchup you like fries a
Oliver yes as long as it just doesn't
become too much if he can get the other
one point our guy made he's a made this
guy gets his hands on you at the line of
scrimmage
it's over that's what I really like yeah
it's just like the kid that's the kid
from Auburn to Carleton Dame is the best
jammer I've seen in the draft at this
point he will put you in the first row
of the stadium if he gets his hands on
you say is good with his hands too yeah
this kid is good but I brought anything
you know even back shoulder throws
they're very tough for him come back
because he's gonna stop and then
breaking the ball is not good he's a lot
like a Rasul Douglas and Eric wrong type
of guy right
I just draft him in the third and then
they'll trade him to the pages that was
good thanks okay next one is going to be
Dante Jackson out of LSU I'm gonna have
Fenric read because I am not good at
reading alright so Dante Jackson this is
from tre Ray Ray submission here so pros
he has elite speed that shows up in his
play has so much recovery speed that he
would purposely stay in his backpedal
for too long just to make guys think
they could get by physical with the line
of scrimmage plays press catch technique
and off coverage is naturally sticky and
man breaks on the ball well has played
outside at corner inside at nickel and
even a bit of safety in his junior year
not afraid of contact much more willing
tackler than you would think
cons frame is small can and will be
moved in the run game at times bigger
wide receivers can also box him out on
50/50 balls yes well duck his head at
times when tackling is a willing tackler
but not the most sound right really raw
can be grabby at times ton of dropped
interceptions pro pro comparison ceiling
is generous Jenkins floor is Fabien
Washington thoughts and I'm impressed
I'm afraid
I am you've liked all the scouting I
have guys you guys are awesome
they're doing they really are this kids
interesting okay Trey Rae he's special I
mean you're a special boy Oh Trey right
Dante Jackson special Trey raised pretty
special Scouter weights okay so you have
had word in in the 15 to 30 - you've had
Jackson in the 2nd Carlton Davis in 15
to 30 two eyes eya oliver late second
where are you putting Dante Jackson
I think this kid's a first round talent
now why do you say he's special because
he can mirror you and stay in your hip
pocket like our buddy said just like
Denzel Ward I mean his cover skills are
phenomenal the size is gonna be an issue
on the outside what size we taught me
and we're talking about 510 178 yeah
that's an issue Yeah right and Denzel
Ward's not much bigger so that's why
people like I get a little annoyed
sometimes where we got this guy's the
seventh pick and this guy's know we're
in the bottom or Lattimore yeah I always
configurating Marshawn Lattimore can
shut down Mike Evans right but you know
ward against it might be and there's no
chance they have none no chance I mean
there's mean we talked about it with
Ward we saw college kids catch the ball
over him when he was all over it so that
can promise you the NFL guys are because
some of those guys he's covering are not
gonna be in college Jackson he's a
little bit honey badger ish okay he can
he can really cover he's really
explosive like the buddy said he really
throws his body or his name's Trevor
Trey he's my buddy okay
my buddy Trey said he could he throws
his body yeah it's a little reckless at
times like this tackles he plays nickel
he plays safety he is your ideal nickel
back in the NFL and here we got two good
corners on the outside you go we're
missing this third guy which is very
valuable this day and age in the league
and maybe I've even undervalued it in
prior years I think you may have yeah
this guy can do that and he courts can
play outside but you see better ones
Clinton Rollins
definitely this guy's a special special
explosive athlete like in your overall
you got 15 okay all right let's see
ability to me Rossum killed will throw
his body right acceleration hips
transition they're as good as they get I
mean it doesn't get any but I didn't
think I was gonna like this kid but the
more I watch but
other than the size what's not to like
there's nothing not to like I mean he's
all over people in man-to-man coverage
plays nickel safety competes for the
ball he's physical he's honey badger ish
and the only weakness you can look at is
just the size thing I'm missing
something else I wanted to say [ __ ] your
beeper but yes I was in his acceleration
his explosion his hips Bob seems
concerned like ward no because this
guy's a true corner not a safety like
that where he's gonna throw his body
around like ward though he's amazing in
transition and change of direction stuff
alright next one is going to be J year
Alexander out of Louisville and it is
being read by Fenric but the scouting
report is from Lewis autopass side
Louise tried to send us another scouting
report but he's only getting one he's
getting J ear Alexander Alexander is a
cornerback from Louisville who has
established himself as a playmaker who
can impact the game on defense and in
the return game he's got an aggressive
jam at the line which makes it hard for
most wide receivers to get off with a
clean and release a lot of good jams in
this corner back ya feet to transition
out okay so where am i feet to
transition out I got totally lost okay
when the ball is in the air it's his
ball or no ball always tries to go for
the turnover has awareness to attack the
football in hands of receivers at the
catch point will cut low on bigger and
noticeable stronger ball carriers but is
never afraid to tackle overall Alexander
is a competitive cornerback whose
swagger foot quickness and hip mobility
gives him the ability to play press man
and zone coverage in any scheme what do
you think I mean I've got they're doing
their homework I'll say that
good job Louise I feel like I feel like
a proud papa because I feel like these
guys are listening to us and looking at
the right things that's where I feel
like their Papa proud papa
alright what rounds are you putting
around J year oh like this is for JJ
year okay Oh JA actual player I like jr.
a lot
the only negative on J years that he
there's none a he didn't play every game
this year I like for me I like Jair more
than Denzel Ward so are you saying in
the
10 to 20 range yeah I mean I Wow so he's
your highest rank I think I'd have no
problem with him being 20 or above right
I mean he's somewhere in that I do who
do you have ranked higher Carlton Davis
or joy or Alexander I probably go gyre
Alexander Wow and we have a new number
one corner cha here Alexander okay yeah
all right so let me here give me your
overall you got 13 Denso were there
similar size but the jrx islander plays
so much bigger than Denzel Ward it's
more physical I mean not afraid to throw
his body around he's not as smooth and
fluid in all movements as Ward but he's
but he's better more explosive and he is
a better burst out of transition to make
plays on the ball I mean like the guy
said it's either no one catches it right
he reminds me of a lot of like William
William Jackson who came out of Houston
a few years ago
shidou be a woozy from last year I mean
yeah it's a little raw the tit the the
tight hips a little bit but man this
straight burst is as impressive as it
gets and I never wrote down I wrote was
five ten five was three nine eight so
that just tells you how explosive he is
I can stop on a dime forty seconds the
kids intensity swag you can see like
some complete place an attitude unique
ability to play zone on off watch the QB
like a Marcus Peters and break on the
ball and see both it's very good his
ability to stick a foot in the ground
and burst is as good as it gets in this
trap when he puts his foot and says I'm
going this way he is a top speed within
three steps screw your buzzer he'll get
one more point in there and he's a
phenomenal returner I mean he has the
ability to be one of the best punt
returners in the sport right really yeah
he's a special guy at that yes hold on I
only play games you know that has values
return as well but do ya like ward I
wrote one of the things too is you don't
get to see him cover anybody top notch
that's my dear last corner but I like
his strength his burst and his ball
skills make it close with the ward thing
and I like his size and physicality
better yeah nice yeah all right Chah
here Alexander and the last one is Kevin
Tolliver the second being scouted by
Conor O'Neill we can't go with him
because you're not even putting my
number one corner in the list right now
my last
you ever missing my number let's get
through kept you have a number one that
we haven't said yes
stay tuned for Sims is number one corner
that we Kevin Tolliver I didn't watch
him yet so there's no point in reading
it so Conor O'Neill I'd like to formally
apologize I don't know where's the other
LSU kid I don't yeah he's the kid okay
alright well then that means that I
don't have the keys in the class of
these guys I love this I think you're a
little then I have a name that's not
even on the list well I need one quick
question who do you have higher Dante
Jackson or Denzel Ward man I'll bet say
Denzel word but it's barely so that
means that you have Denzel Ward is your
fourth ranked corner Sims right now with
whom my 3mj ear and that's all burned
kid ahead of them it's just kind of fun
ranking this live yeah I know it is good
you have any good time today I am good
yeah radio in ten minutes I know we're
watching the clock yeah
that means you're seventh ranked corner
is Isaiah Oliver your sixth ranked
corner is Josh Jackson your fifth ranked
corner is Dante Jackson your fourth
ranked corner
Denzel Ward your third ranked corner
Carlton Davis your second ranked corner
J year Alexander and sims's number one
corner of the class of 2018 is
my cues and news Central Florida yes sir
Wow let us hear about my cues in Central
Florida all right so so when I went on
that rant the other day about saying
that Shekinah Griffin was clearly good
because there's no one on this UCF
defense I was off by a little bit I
accuse UCF oh damn I want to pull all
right first of all he ran out four or
five okay what pics are we talking right
now I mean to me this is the be the guy
that goes at 7:00 he's the best corner
in the draft for me Wow
I mean yes okay first of all he's the
best returner in the draft - even better
than Jay Alexander where there are my
charkh in Ellis you just said the jail
examiner could be one of the best
returners in the game and this kid can
be right up there and he'd give me
better he's better than gyre as a
returner yeah yes this gets special with
the ball on his hands start off with the
overall and then work your way back I
like when you start with your last pair
okay all right I'll do that sorry all
right so I just want to say this first
of all you ran four or five three he
plays a lot faster than four cut three
like you know that doesn't mean
everything okay but either way okay so
my last thing is man big fan of this kid
he's in the cabo for the best
quarterback in the draft
I mean Ward cornerback is if Ward is
everyone's number one well I wrote [ __ ]
I like him better than Ward he's a true
shut down number-one cornerback Wow he's
haven't said that yet his strengths and
toughs will allow him to cover big wide
receivers a sudden like SMU I saw it it
I saw it on film because they played SMU
and he can be the best punt returner in
football right so I think what I liked
about him first of all is his ability to
jam at the line of scrimmage tackle stay
in the hip pocket of receivers like ward
or the LSU kid I mean his ability in and
out of transition was all top-notch
right yes I wrote like his body smart
cornerback but has good build like his
legs I know he's less than words and
weight but just doesn't look it doesn't
look as sliminess prey
his word you just find out right away
this kids not afraid of contact amazing
feet like ward from Ohio State
he likes to press and get hands on you
he's twitchy as hell and more straight
ahead explosion than Ward I know the top
end is not as good but tackling he's the
best tackling cornerback yet very good
in zone is officially out to accelerate
is his ability to react and accelerate
his top-notch full speed in two to three
steps this kid can play outside because
of strength but he's gonna be more
valuable in the slot to because his side
to side movement hips are all off the
charts good he is really good slot
material his top end would scare me a
little burst burst some of the top end
NFL wide receivers but I'm not even at
the end of my film I wrote not true his
top ends fine because I set to see more
so that's how I go back and correct this
kid a lot I do
I wrote other than Ward I wrote he is
the most efficient and effortless in and
out of transition the more I watch the
more comfortable I am I am with his
top-end speed the 4:3 is not lit you
know and the four or five three is not
his real time I want to give a special
shout out no one ever really ever gets
open against this kid this is where I
miss the ending thing no one ever gets
open like I watched I mean almost every
coverage snap of them together I said
there's nobody ever opened this guys
catch you from time to time sure and
then I wrote this [ __ ] Hawks
everyone and you know I love hawkers so
Sims a left go especially Sims when
there's a wide receiver running down the
field and you see a guy come out of
nowhere
it's called Hawking yes and that's what
Goodwin did to Patrick Peterson
interception right and that is a true
sign of speed yeah when you need to hit
the afterburners can you do it
oh my god I want to give a special shout
out to Bret Threlkeld Mitch Neeson Colin
can I call you Colin Bryan her knee Trey
Ray Lewis Oropesa and Conor O'Neill guys
thank you so much for sending in your
scouting reports that is now Sims is
cornerback rankings Mike Hughes J
Alexander Carleton Davis Denzel Ward
Dante Jackson Josh Jackson Isiah Oliver
that is your top seven good convo and I
think those four I'm up for argument on
all the Hughes chair Carlton and Denzel
yes but would you put Dante in there to
say is they ease a little bit of a
different animal because I don't think
his value on the outside is up there
with them becomes a true slide is a true
slot guy the first round grades on
Hughes Alexander Carlton and Denzel all
at some point in the first Dante Jack's
and Dante Jackson yeah so you have those
five guys so which one of those with the
Patriots be most interested in if uses I
would imagine Hughes let's say is gone
right man Jair Carlton maybe Carlton he
sounds more like that I think the
Stephon Gilmore is I don't know what
they're they're maybe want to go the
Malcolm Butler yeah go joy year they can
also fill Amendola z' role of returner
no doubt it's interesting guys those are
his takes I'd love to hear your takes
about his takes this is a packed show
but it's on Wednesday and that's what we
do it so we throw stone 160 I enjoyed
the conversation with big phil simms we
even got the throwback of the music we
gotta go thank you as always for
subscribing on itunes go and check that
out now for sims he's out homey for
Fenric good night everyone
for the lef koe man thank you guys for
watching on youtube as always subscribe
on itunes and share with your friends we
are in the process of getting
merchandise made our one shirt will be
coming out soon I'm not gonna tell you
what it's about but I'm excited for it
love you guys have a great night have a
great weekend we'll holler at you on
Monday be well